c'était il y a dix huit ans une
professeur agrégé d'économie prend la
parole pour défendre sa retraite je vais
partir à la retraite au delà de 2020
donc il faut rajouter 10 jusqu'à 68 ans
puisque j'ai commencé à travailler à 26
ans et je partirai avec 38 % de mon
salaire net c'est la première fois qu'on
voit nathalie arthaud à la télévision
simple militante en 2003 elle s'impose
petit à petit au sein du parti de lutte
ouvrière un parti d'extrême gauche
communiste révolutionnaire incarné par
une femme arlette laguiller et bien oui
je suis une femme et j'ose me présenter
comme candidate à la présidence de cette
république d'hommes six fois candidate à
la présidentielle elle laisse sa place à
la tête du parti en 2007 et c'est là que
nathalie arthaud arrivent sur le devant
de la scène parmi les successeurs
possibles mises en lumière dans ce parti
où on cultive le secret nathalie arthaud
37 ans porte parole de lutte ouvrière
dans la région lyonnaise les à
l'entendre rien n'est fait voilà je la
compagne parce qu'on est en meeting à
lyon quant aux présidentielles c'est
dans cinq ans donc là vraiment je crois
qu'on a le temps de voir tout ça donc
c'est pas vraiment d'actualité pour
l'instant n'est pas vraiment d'actualité
mais ces sourires en disent long puisque
quelques mois plus tard nathalie arthaud
38 ans est la nouvelle porte parole de
lutte ouvrière mais difficile pour elle
de se faire un nom dans l'ombre
d'arlette laguiller est grande
nathalie arthaud la nouvelle arlette
comme on risque de la surnommer regardez
la bien pratiquement le même âge la même
coiffure et le même journal entre les
mains elle vous rappelle forcément cette
jeune femme politique qui crevait
l'écran dans les années 70 arlette
laguiller nathalie arthaud même en
fermant les yeux on pourrait les
confondre et c'est vrai travailleuses
travailleurs travailleuses travailleurs
le style elle-même l'ennemi est le même
en 2012 pour sa première campagne
présidentielle
nathalie arthaud s'attaque au
capitalisme nous nous sommes communiste
révolutionnaire on pense que cette
société capitaliste à l'état renversé un
call a fait faillite quel est au bout du
rouleau aux élections de 2012 et 2017 la
candidate des ouvriers fait des scores
historiquement bas elle récolte moins de
1% des voix seule certitude aujourd'hui
pour le premier meeting de campagne de
nathalie arthaud 1 il ne résonnera une
nouvelle fois
[Musique]